well we got us attention what the hell
step 2
what's the story of since the policy
rounding the cube is impenetrable
doors right you got to deal with these
guys how do we do this at the team I
have unfinished business with Loki yeah
get in line save it
Loki's gonna keep this fight focused on
us and that's what we need without him
these things to run wild we got stark up
top he's gonna need us so this all seems
horrible I've seen worse sorry yeah we
could use a little worse stuck we got
him
banner just like you said then tell him
to suit up I'm bringing the party to you
I don't see how that's a party
dr. banner now it might be a really good
time for you to get angry that's my
secret that I'm always angry
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
send the rest
[Music]
guys call it good all right listen up
until we can close that portal our
priority is containment Martin I want
you on that roof eyes on everything call
out patterns and strays Stark you got
the perimeter anything gets more than
three blocks out to turn it back or you
turn it to ash and give me lift right
later clench up Legolas
Thor you got a try and bottleneck that
portal slow him down
you got the lightning like the bastard
tell you and me we stay here on the
ground keep the fighting here and Hulk
smash
[Music]
you
you